cross your fingers and pray hard as
sonic team leader Takashi Iizuka has
said that sonic could return to consoles
please don't be terrible I'm said
forward with your GS news update
refusing to let him rest his weary feet
sonic could once again be shuffled out
of the retirement home to run jump and
spin all over our shiny new consoles the
hedgehogs last console outing sonic boom
in late 2014 failed to impress anyone
whatsoever landing a gamespot review
score of two out of ten and we weren't
even the worst speaking 24 gamer after
translation azucar said please rest
assured I personally have no plans to
stop making sonic games for home
consoles the comments come after Sega
cut 300 jobs in late January in order to
focus production on mobile and online pc
titles given sonic boom was not
developed in-house with Sonic Team it's
actually entirely possible his next
sprint adventure could be good the
team's last attempt was the ios and
android title sonic runners azucar was
of course speaking personally about his
own ambitions it's not certain where the
Sega would actually greenlight new sonic
projects for consoles is it time to let
the poor old guy rest or is there one
last great Sonic game left to be had
leave us a comment below will send the
better suggestions straight to Sega and
for more gaming news stay tuned to
gamespot com